[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للابناء الصعبه المندائيين هم
يقطنون مثل ما معروف للجميع انهم يقتلونا
جنوب العراق منذ مئات السنين بالالاف
السنين
اخذ تعدادهم بالتناقص بحقيقه هي بدايه
الهجره من التسعينات تعرف انت بدايه عدم
استقرار العراق بدايه
انه العراق اخذ منحه جديد
سياسه العراقيه بدات تاخذ من حاجه جديد
والنظره الدوليه للعراق بعد ذلك بدات
الهجره لكن بعدها قليله جدا لكن لا تكاد
ان تحسب
[موسيقى]
بدات الهجره الفعليه والكبيره بعد 2003
حيث ان النظام بعد انهياره تعرف تغيرت
امور كثيره على قرات على الساحه العراقيه
لا نقول فقط السابقه وانهم السابقه
والايزيدين والمسيحيين وكل الاقليات ايييه
اخذوا بالتناقص اعدادهم تتناقص في العراق
بعد ان كانوا يحسبونا بالمئات الالوف
اصبحوا يعدون بالالاف او اقل من ذلك
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لنظام السياسي الجديد مدعام 2003
الى الان لا تزال سياسه الاخصاء والتهمش
بحق ابناء المكونات الصغيره ومنها المكون
المندائيين مستمره
الحكومات عاجزه
عن ايه
تطبيق مبدا التوازن والمساواه بين
المكونات جميعا وخصوص المكونات الصغيره
هذا واضح
يعني يعود يسبب الحقيقي على انه عدم
ايمانهم بفكره اشراك المكونات في اداره
الدوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]